[موسيقى]
خمسه من الضفادع كانت تجلس فوق صخره في
بحيره صغيره قرر احدها القفز في الماء فكم
ضفدع عن بقي على الصخره سؤال وجهه استاذ
جامعي لطلابه فسخروا في سرهم من سؤال
يوجهه للاطفال وليس للشباب لكن المفاجاه
ان اجابات جميع الطلاب كانت خاطئه
باستثناء واحد منهم ابلغهم الاستاذ
فالطالب الحادق اجاب خمسه الخمسه بقوا على
الصخره لان الضفدع المقدام قرر القفز في
الماء ولم يخبرنا احد بعد انه قفز وقد لا
يقفز ابدا
وهكذا نحن البشر نقرر اشياء كثيره وننفذ
منها القليل والعبره ليست بالاقوال
والاشعار بل بالثبات على المبادئ
وبانجازات ترنور
الى العناوين
قطر تعلن عن قرب نفادي تذاكر المونديال
برغم نفاق المشويشين
ابو تريكه لن نبدل ديننا لاجل كاس العالم
بوتين رفاهيه الغرب قائمه على نهد افريقيا
وافقارها
قديروف يصف زينسكي بالعفريت ويعرض عليه
وظيفه
ديمقراطيه نطيطه والزحليقه في انتخابات
البحرين
اضطهاد المسلمين واساءات للاسلام في الهند
واستراليا ومالي
حواس يريد اسكات الاذان والهام تنتقد
تغييب المشاهد الخلاعيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا كان هؤلاء نشطاء بيئيين يقتحبون
مطعم في باريس لتنفيذ وقفه دقيقه صمت
حدادا على ارواح الدجاج ليقنع العالم بان
ذبح الحيوانات واكلها حرام بيئيا وفي
الهند جرد متطرفون هندوس رجلين مسلمين من
الملابس
وجلدهما قبل ان تعتق لهما الشرطه بحجه
حيزته ما لحم ابقار تحرم الديانه
الهندوسيه ذبحها ويفتي المتطرفون بذبح من
ياكلها
تخيلوا لو ان عقيده تقديس البقر وتحريم
اللحوم فرضت ثقافتها في الارض كم كان
العالم سيبدو كئيبا ومبللا وذائعا
تخيلوا ايضا لو ان بعض الغرب فرض غرائبه
الاجتماعيه على كل العالم كم كنا نبعد عن
نهايه العالم في الغرب هناك من يدعو الان
من منطلقات ثقافيه الى مقاطعه مونديال قطر
عاشيه انطلاقه يتم ذلك بقليل من التاييد
وكثير من النفاق بحسب الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني نائب رئيس مجلس الوزراء
القطري وزير الخارجيه الذي اعلن عن اقتراب
تذاكر حضور المونديال من النفاذ واكد ان
شرائها قد تم من كافه ارجاء الارض بما
فيها الدول التي تنطلق منها الاصوات
المشوشه على عرس العالم الكروي بالضيافه
العربيه لاول مره في التاريخ
عينه عن بعض الاعتراضات الثقافيه على قطر
ليست الا وساما يعلق على صدور القطريين
والعرب والمسلمين
شروطها على كل من يحضر ان على سبيل المثال
انه لا يجب ان يقيم شخص مع صديقته ما لم
يكن متزوج بعده
[موسيقى]
يعني يفك الغاز اعقد الالغاز وزير
الخارجيه القطري محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال
ثاني المانيا في مقابله مع نشرتها صحيفه
المانيه بازدواجيه المعايير بسبب
انتقاداتها لسجل حقوق الانسان في بلده
وقال انه ليست لدى الحكومه الالمانيه
مشكله معنا عندما يتعلق الامر بشراكات او
استثمارات رجال الطاقه بعد ايام من
استدعاء الخارجيه القطريه السفيره
الالمانيه في الدوحه وتسليبه مذكره احتجاج
على تصريحات للوزيره الالمانيه نانسي فيزر
اعتبرت تجاوزا للاصول الدبلوماسيه تصل
فيزر الى الدوحه وتجري مباحثات تصفها
بالايجابيه للغايه
وتسيد بحزمه القوانين التي سنتها قطر خلال
السنوات الاخيره كثير من الناس يقولون ان
هناك تحسينات تحققت وهذا امر جيد وايضا
عندما سالنا عنا اذا كان هذا سيستمر الى
ما بعد كاس العالم كانت الاجابه بثقه نعم
بشكل لا لبس فيه حصلت على نظره ثاقبه
وايجابيه للغايه من هذه المحادثات الجيده
حقا بكل الاحوال لن نغير ما في كاسنا لاجل
كاس العالم فذهبون وتاقلب معنا يقول النجم
العربي محمد ابو تريكه لن نبدل ديننا
وتقاليدنا عشان 28 يوم قطر هتبهر العالم
فالحمالات الغربيه ما تخوفناش كل دي نعمه
المسلمين وهتقدم لكم بطوله انسانيه في
المقام الاول وبعد كده اتفرجوا على دوله
عربيه بتحترم تقاليدها وعددها احنا مش
هنغير ديننا ولا نغير عاداتنا ولا قوانين
بلادنا عشان 28 يوم انت لازم تتاقلم علينا
وتعرفنا عشان تعرف تتعامل معانا كويس
المتشدد في الغرب مكرمه للدوحه هو انه
سيستقبل اسرائيليين بحسب الاعلام العبري
فالباب القطري الموصده رسميا امام لجين
سيفتح على مصرعيه مع استعداد الوفي
الاسرائيليين لدخول الدوحه من شباك كاس
العالم هؤلاء سيطرون لشراء بطاقات قطريه
لهواتفهم الجوالات تقول قناه كان
الاسرائيليه الرسميه بعد لفظ الدوحه
التعاون مع شركات الاتصالات الاسرائيليه
علما ان قطر قد رفضت في سبتمبر الماضي
طلبه الابيب بفتح قنصليه لها خلال فتره
المونديال في الدوحه
التصريحات التي اشتهر بها المسؤولون
الايطاليون ضد فرنسا يتبناها الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ويطلقها على سائر
الدول الاستعماريه التي ما كانت لتعيش
الرفاهيه بدون ان تذهب افريقيا والباحثون
الاوروبيون لا ينكرون ذلك يقول
بالقتل قويه
افريقيا لم ينسى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان تصريح المسؤول الاوروبيه الرفيع
جوزيف حول اوروبا الحديقه والعالم الغابه
وراى مع مفعول رجعي ان الرجعيه بريل عبرت
فعلا عن العقليه الاوروبيه الاستعلائيه
اعطيني لعبه
الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان
وفي تنمر على مهنه عمال تنظيفات يعرض
قديروف
منصب كبير عمال النظافه
التوام
تلفزيون منور
[موسيقى]
البابا فرنسيس دعى حكومه البحرين الى ضمان
واحترام الحريات الانسانيه والدينيه
وغلطه دعوته كل القنوات الاخباريه في
الارض وبينها قناه الجزيره التي حملتها
المنامه مسؤوليه خطاب البابا ببيان رسمي
امام الملك حمد بن عيسى الخليفه الى وقف
العمل بعقوبه الاعدام والالتزام بالحريات
الدينيه والكرامه المتساويه وانهاء
التمييز قبل ان يستغرق البابا فيما وصف
بالانتقاد غير المباشر لحكومه البحرين هل
تفضل البابا بالاطلاع على ديمقراطيه
البحرين التي تمارس بروح رياضيه تشمل
النطيطه والزحليقه
الانتخابي للمرشح انيابي محمد بن جاسم
الدواجن وعلى هذا المسرح عندي ايش هدايا
العاب تسالي كل شيء حق الحلوين موجود حتى
الالعاب نطيطه زحليقه كل ما تتمناه في
التسالي والترفيه موجود عندنا في هذا
المقر ومسابقات حقكم كلكم وهدايا شين
هتشيل من الهدايا وتسمع من الهدايا بس
تعالوا عندنا مدينه خليفه وبعد الانتهاء
من العاب الاطفال
بامكان الناخبين المفترضين اي توجهوا نحو
عشاء مفتوح لمرشح اخر
وهناك الاكل على قدر المحبه وعلى
نيه الاقتراع
اعترض ضيف بحريدي على وصف مذيع بي بي سي
للبحرين بالدوله البحرين مش دوله البحرين
مملكه
وليست دوله لنتكرت كذا مره في حديثك ان
دوله البحرين ومنها هي مملكه البحرين
نفسه المعترض على وصف البحرين بالدوله يصف
البحرين بالدوله صلاه نقول ان البحرين
دوله مؤسسات ولها جهاز القضائي المستقل
اسوه بقيه الدول الاخرى ان ثبات البحرين
على علاقاتها مع اسرائيل لن يتاثر بصعود
نتنياهو او حتى الزومبي الى الحكم في تل
ابيب في البحرين تؤكد سنواصل بناء على
قاتنا مع اسرائيل حتى بعد قدومه لرئاسه
وزراء من جديد لتشكيل حكومه تعتبر الاكثر
يمنيه في تاريخ اسرائيل لكن الاسرائيليين
يعتبرون ان الرابح الاكبر هو اثمار بينج
فيرت زعيم وتحالف الصهيونيه الدينيه
بحجج مختلفه وواهيه لا تختلف عن حجج
السلطات الاسرائيليه في الاعتداء على
مقدسات المسلمين
والمسيحيين فيما قام محامون هندوس دعوى
قضائيه يزعمون فيها باحقيتهم في هدم مسجد
وتحويله الى معبد هندوسي بدعوه انه كان
كذلك من قبل بينما ذكر صحيح دي اوب ذا
باور النصر السلطات الهنديه تستهدف الالاف
من المساجد سعيا الى هدبها ومنع المسلمين
من ممارسه الشعائرهم اجبرت مدرسه استراليه
بيضه مسلمه على مشاهده فيديو يجسد النبي
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم بطريقه مسيئه الى
مقامه الشريف الامور مع المسلمين ليست
معقده
مقدساتهم ليست للاستهزاء او حتى الاستخفاء
عقيدتهم ترفض التطابل على مقدسات الاخرين
وتطاول الاخرين على مقدساتهم فماذا يجدي
المتطاولون غير الفتنه وتسميم الاسواق
الاف المسلمين في مالي تظاهروا بدعوه من
المجلس الاسلامي الاعلى في البلاد احتجاجا
على بث شريط فيديو يسيء الى القران الكريم
وللاسلام بشكل عام
محمد رسول الله
احد معاقل المتطرفين الهندوس وصل الامر
باضطهاد المسلمين الى ساحل طفلين منهم
بالسياره
ونمتنعوا عن عرض المشاهد القاسيه تداول
ناشطنا مدنيون مقطعا مصورا من الهند
يظهروا قياما متطرفين هندوس بسحر طفلين
مسلمين بالسياره
وزير الاثار المصري الاسبق زاهي حواس يحول
نفسه الى تلميذ عند ابراهيم عيسى الذي
اشتهر في مصر بتقديسه البقر حواس مرهف
والحواس ولاسيمه تلك المعلقه والمتعلقه
باذنيه فيؤيد طرحه ابراهيم عيسى في الدعاء
ان اذاعه الاذان مزعجه وتطرد السياح
حواس اساء الادب مع الاذان براي شيخ ازهري
عندما قال الادندا
بيتعمل جوه المسجد دوله سياحيه فلازم برده
نحافظ على راس السايح ففي حاجات كثير جدا
موجوده
عشان نقدر نجيب السائح طبعا ده شكوى
بيفتكروا منها سواح في مكان كبير جدا ومش
موجود في اي بلد في الدنيا
فلماذا لا يؤذن المسلمون للصلاه سؤال
يطرحه عالم الاجتماع الديني البريطاني
بجامعه اصفر لبروفيسور ريتشارد
فهل تبعثه بريطانيا لنا لبروفيسور المحترم
ريتشارد وتاخذ منا زاهيه ورده على سؤال
بس اذان المسلمين في المملكه المتحده قال
ماكلهم في مقال الصحفيين نشرت هو بريمارك
كريستيان البريطانيه ان ذلك حق من حقوق
مسلمي المملكه في ما دامت الكنائس تدق
اجراسها فلماذا لا يؤذن المسلمون للصلاه
الممثله الهام شاهين عاصرت التلفزيونين
الابيض والاسود والملون وتدعي ان نساء مصر
في ايامها كنا بدون حجابات لكن الماده
الدينيه والفكره الوهابيه سببات تراجع على
المشاهد الخلاعيه في السينما هي تسميها
مشاهد جريئه
[موسيقى]
هو تراجع في المجتمع كله مش في السينما
لانه انت في السبعينات والثمانينات ما
كنتيش بتلاقي واحده محجبه في الشارع مثلا
افلام الابيض واسود كلها ما فيهاش ولا
نجمه محجبه انتم ما كانش فيه
هذا
المد الديني والفكر الوهابي اللي بدا يدخل
ويسيطر لحد كبير
على مقاسي سلوكها تعترف بانها غير مستقره
وغير قادره على تحمل المسؤوليه ففضلت
الاجهاض المتكرر على الامومه
صح
من كرمال شغلك
حسيت ان انا مش هكون قد المسؤوليه ومش
هاجيب طفل يتعذب وخصوصا ان انا مش مستقره
حسنه ممكن اطلق عليه الطفل يتربى الام في
مكان والاب في مكان ما كنت حاسه اني
مستقره
المصريين مصابون بالاكتئاب وان نسبه
الانتحاري في الارتفاع نتيجه للازمات
العالميه ووباء الكرونه يعني الحرب في
اوكرانيا والكورونا في الصين بينما
الانتحار بسببهما في مصر
والخاله الهام والاسطى حواس تركيب الناس
تنتحر او تتظاهر في الساحات وملاحقين
الاذان والحجاب المصريين بيعانوا بنسبه
25% من الاكتئاب والامراض والاضطرابات
النفسيه ده بقى خلينا نقول انه النتيجه
ليه ازمات متلاحقه عالميه بالتاكيد
الامارات لعين كالكونه بالتاكيد نحن نتحدث
عن حالات انتحار عاليه
[موسيقى]
رئيسا جديدا للتجمع الوطني خلفا لمريض
لوبان بعدما فاز على عمده
اليوم وهو ايضا شريك حياتي لوبان سابقا
لحظه تاريخيه بالنسبه للحزب اليمني
المتطرف فهي المره الاولى التي يتزعم
الحزب شخص من خارج عائله للثاني بعد سنوات
مؤسسته وبلبه التجمع الوطني في فرنسا عن
زعامه الحزب اليمني المتطرف فهل ستتنازل
عائله الرئيس السابق الجنرال ميشيل عون عن
رئاسه التيار الوطني الحر اليمني سؤال
يطرح في لبنان رئيس التيار وصهره عون
النائب جبران باسيل حاول لاستهزاء بمحاوره
الصحفي سامي كليب بسؤاله عن مستوى ذكائه
الاي كيو
وهكذا كانت النتيجه
غوار الطوشه الى سده المسرح السياسي من
غربه الى كاسك يا بطل وشقائق النعمان
وضيعه تشرين
الامور اصلا حتى اصوات القصور
الاصوات الصواريخ المضاده يعني مش معها
بالشغل لانه نعرف انه بالحاله في اعتداء
وفي مقاومه ارضيه هم يستغلون بعض الطائرات
المدنيه ويطلقون من تحتها او من فوقيها
في هذه الحاله عندما ترد الصواريخ السوريه
ستصيب قد تصيب بعض الطيران المدني وبعد
ذلك يقع اللوم علينا لذلك نحن لا نفعل انا
ما في نميز بين الحق والباطل هل فعلا في
امه عربيه ولا كذبه تاريخيه انا هلا ما
عندي هذا الامام بصراحه همم في مجموعه
امامها وفي المتفرقات العربيه ايضا رجال
الدفاع المدني العراقي تعرضوا لاصابات
اثناء اطفائهم حريقا في بغداد فنقلوا الى
مستشفى لم تتسع اسرته للجميع فكانت
الفضيحه ان وضعت ثنائيات المصابين على
سرير واحد وفضحتها الكاميرا اثناء تصويرها
جوله وزيري الصحه والداخليه على المصابين
حبيبه اوزدمر حبيبه محرم اردوغان هي عازبه
في سن ال 90 وهو ارمله في السابعه
والسبعين قصه حبهما بدات قبل سبع سنوات
بعد لقاء في مركز علاج صحي وقد توجت
بالزواج
[موسيقى]
اخيرا نازحه تحت خيمه في ريف ادلب بسوريا
لا تريد ان تفك وحدتها مثل حبيبه التركيه
بل كل ما ترجوه هو ان تاكل حتى تقدر تنام
والله
انا عارف
نهار اسود
نهار ابيض
[موسيقى]
ودمعتاه وهو يقول بين سرهره اذا لماذا لا
تريدني اي مكالمه او حتى رساله من ابنائي
الخلاصه احفظ اهلك فالعقوق اهلك كل من حق
فمن اكرم ممن اكرم والديه وكم خاب من
انصرف عنهما لاي عرض او غرض في الدنيا الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
يا رب
يا رب يا رب ما تخش الجنه مع النبي
في الجنه مع النبي يا رب يا
[موسيقى]
رب